[Música]
a
quiero contaros una pequeña anécdota
para empezar y es lo siguiente el día 22
de diciembre me hacen un tag por una
cosa que había tenido y me sacan que
tengo un tumor en el páncreas por eso
parece que es una cosa muy seria y
sabéis que hice bueno no sabe que eso te
cuesta unos cuantos meses de vida y
seguir trabajando porque porque me
parece que la creación yo soy un
científico la creación es tan importante
que todo lo que hagas por el planeta por
las personas vale la pena hacerlo así
que dije que mejor dedicarme a eso que
no a las pequeñas cosas bueno el día 2
de enero me lo vuelven a hacer y me
dicen muchacho no tienes nada
el resultado fue que dije sigo
trabajando
así que como si no hubiera ocurrido nada
por qué pues porque creo que los
mensajes sobreviven a las personas las
personas pasamos pero los mensajes no y
cuando uno reflexiona sobre el futuro
soy miembro del club de roma soy un
científico que está dedicado a hacer
tesis doctorales ya ya ya formar a
personas de todo el mundo pues entonces
lo único que podéis hacer es decir bueno
pues esto es lo que he hecho y con ese
esto es lo que he hecho a ver si con eso
os puede ayudar a ver si podemos cambiar
un poco el mundo
pues bien empiezo con una idea es
evidente y es conocida la amenaza del
cambio climático vosotros habéis visto
las sequías que están teniendo lugar
incendios fusión de los polos subida del
nivel del mar inundaciones
todo eso es claro que necesitamos una
transición ecológica y lo que es más
importante es que a partir de ahora
hasta el año 2040
tenemos que reducir nuestras emisiones a
cero una se podrán hacer utilizando
energías renovables y otras habrá que
compensar las pero hay que hacerlo hay
que hacerlo entonces fijaos en 25 años
vamos a tener que cambiar completamente
el planeta no nuestra sociedad
desarrollada todo el planeta todo el
planeta entonces esto es una cosa que la
tenemos o sí o no porque si es no
de alguna manera que lo vais a pagar
vais a ser vosotros la gente joven no
hay derecho que nuestra generación ha
destruido y sin embargo vosotros vais a
recibir una herencia de degradación es
bien
la cuestión es que se nos anuncian
mundos digamos bastante bastante felices
como qué
las renovables vendrán tendremos un
vehículo eléctrico va a haber una
digitalización universal
parece que no va a haber impactos
ambientales y de la otra manera
mirando la alimentación pues dice pues
que hay que alimentar a 9.000 millones
de individuos
y comen todos los días y habrá esa
superpoblación que genera problemas una
urbanización etcétera etcétera entonces
cuando uno es científico y de alguna
manera quiere ver el futuro pues se
plantea
qué va a pasar y uno mira los números y
cuando uno mira los números lo siguiente
que si nos centramos en el transporte y
no voy a dar toda la tipo de información
pero sí algunos mil 320 millones de
vehículos funcionaban en el año 2016
ahora muchos más el parque de vehículos
se duplica cada 20 años y evidentemente
esos vehículos no duran toda la vida 8
15 años máximo entonces la cantidad de
vehículos que se preparan son enormes y
además de todos esos lo que más son
vehículos eléctricos e híbridos que
tendrán que entrar necesariamente para
que las energías fósiles se vayan
desplazando pues bien esto uno se
pregunta
eso es el futuro del vehículo eléctrico
pues bueno este es uno de los problemas
no de los problemas una de las
soluciones hay otra solución y es el
tema de el internet de las cosas antes a
comentarles stephen ha hablado te el
internet de las cosas y en el internet
de las cosas se nos espera un mundo pues
muy interesante un mundo todo conectado
en el cual esa conexión de personas a
personas de personas a cosas y de cosas
a cosas nos va a llevar a un mundo en lo
cual no lo conocemos pero la cantidad de
posibilidades que hay es inmensa y
entonces eso uno se pregunta
a cuántos teléfonos móviles equivale eso
en los próximos años
hoy hay en el mundo 4700 millones de
teléfonos móviles
el mercado global para el año 2023 es
decir 4 años se habla ya de mil millones
de dólares anuales y creciendo esto es
lo que va a pasar en el futuro es un
futuro tan cerca como bueno habréis
visto era alexa de amazon por decir algo
y ahí tenéis los equipos que aparecerán
sensores de todo tipo de vibración de
luz de presión de humedad potenciómetros
cámaras plc sólo logra más robots
antenas todo todo va a ser simplemente
cambiado por estas nuevas tecnologías
algo bien
la cuestión es
tendremos que dar energía tendremos que
mantener eso tenemos que darle energía a
que los vehículos funcionen a que el
internet de las cosas la digitalización
funcione pues bien esa implementación de
energías renovables que tiene que
sustituir a los combustibles fósiles no
nos lleva nada menos a que si esto era
el balance vayan seguido para atrás a
donde estamos aquí se ha ido el balance
de 12 por ciento y esa esfera ganando
volumen tendremos que multiplicar en los
próximos está una generación en vuestra
vida nuestra generación
tendremos que multiplicarlo por más de
50 veces energía eólica energía
fotovoltaica todas las energías
renovables tendremos que ponerlas y eso
también es otra de los vectores del
futuro pues bien cuando uno dice eso
dice y esto está exento de impacto
medioambiental
puedes mirar la cara oculta de la luna
también existe y yo le llamo la cara
oculta a esas cosas que no nos dicen
acerca de qué se necesita para llegar a
ese mundo es decir el nexo común es un
uso masivo exponencial de recursos
naturales y aquí es donde empezamos a
preocuparnos y trabajamos llevamos ya 20
años trabajando en esto con tesis
doctorales con a nivel de una red
internacional de colegas que estamos
trabajando en estas cosas
un aerogenerador necesita cosas como
imanes permanentes que necesitan y obvio
perdón y obvio neodimio disprosio por
supuesto hierro aluminio cobre níquel
pero es que un panel fotovoltaico de
alta calidad necesita teluro cadmio
indio galio y selenio
y hay tantos minerales para todo eso y
un vehículo eléctrico un vehículo
eléctrico necesita ni más ni menos que
50 metales de los cuales muchos de ellos
son metales materiales críticos
y estoy trabajando en este tema que pasa
aquí aquí trabajando en este tema nos
dimos cuenta que mientras digamos en los
años 50 apareció el 600 la cantidad de
metales raros que tenía era poca
conforme fue
evolucionando la tecnología la cantidad
de metales era cada vez mayor hoy
estamos en el vehículo ya híbrido y
eléctrico y ya estamos hablando de 50
metales pero es que para el año 2040
2050 ya ya existen los vehículos
autónomos esos vehículos autónomos están
llenos de materiales raros bueno pues
esto
solamente es una parte porque si miramos
el tema del teléfono móvil que tenemos
todos nada menos que hay 31 elementos en
vuestro teléfono móvil 31 elementos
algunos tan raros como el tántalo o el
cobalto o el cobalto o la plata el oro
el galio el indio
el brasero dime o el lantano el europeo
ha dado line o cosas que evidentemente
no las habréis ha oído muchos de
vosotros
la cuestión es que esto la el planeta
que es finito no tiene para todo y para
todos bien aquí no se vemos esto y veis
que se va a utilizar en la domótica en
el comercio en la industria en las
ciudades en la energía en la medicina
todas estas cosas se van a utilizar
porque nos va a cambiar el mundo y todo
ello requiere metales raros y entonces
cuál es el número de móviles
equivalentes que vamos a si hoy tenemos
cuatro mil 700 millones cuántos
teléfonos móviles equivalentes vamos a
tener en los próximos años en forma de
esos sensores pues nosotros hemos
estimado que por lo menos 20 veces más
20 veces más bien y estamos hablando no
en una generación sino mucho menos bien
la cuestión es nos identificamos con el
internet de las cosas y yo me pregunto
somos idiotas
necesitamos capear necesitamos cambiar
hay que saber esto hay que saber esto y
entonces mirar hay que aprender de la
naturaleza en las zonas engendran
bonitos y las sumadas humanitos
y los móviles
y los coches
y los robots
basura
es que esto hay que cambiarlo
esto hay que cambiarlo entonces la
solución las cambia borde sexo
es decir ahora le vamos a llamar las
móviles las coches las robots
o lo que hay que hacer es recuperar los
equipos para que hagan nuevos equipos
es decir
igual que la naturaleza crea sus propios
a especie y se reproduce porque no
diseñamos las cosas para que las cosas
que hacemos los seres humanos se
reproduzcan bien
hay que ir a una economía circular
general el fin de vida de un equipo no
es el fin de vida de sus componentes
cuando un coche la chatarra mos estamos
achatarrando las cosas que funcionan las
que no funcionan hombre que hay que
recuperar eso otro todos los equipos
tienen partes que pueden ser
reutilizadas otro hay que diseñar para
reutilizar hay que diseñar hay que
aprender a diseñar para desensamblar
para reutilizar para que las cosas duren
y por supuesto ningún equipo
ningún equipo debería venderse sin
añadir sus contraindicaciones y sus
contraindicaciones fijar la industria
farmacéutica pues está sin problemas
cuando sacas una medicina lo que te dice
esa industria es que primero mira las
contraindicaciones y no sea que lo que
yo te ofrezco para sanarse resulta que
te está provocando unas
contraindicaciones que son peor que lo
que te sana entonces por qué no
planteamos ese tema a nivel social
realmente un análisis de las
contraindicaciones de todo esto que está
saliendo porque hay algunas cosas que
nuestros móviles nuestros móviles en
algunos aspectos tienen sangre detrás
tienen sangre detrás bien bueno pues
entonces nos fascina vamos con la
rapidez de las innovaciones si la
economía celebra el crecimiento yo que
soy físico termodinámico
y pensar que a todo crecimiento a todo
beneficio se asocia una pérdida de
recursos naturales y eso no lo
escuchamos esa es la parte la cara
oculta de la luna es la que nunca nos
contarán y hay que hacerlo y no hay que
hacerlo simplemente para decir qué malo
somos no os quiero decir que es para
cambiar la tecnología cambiar la
sociedad cambiar las empresas de tal
manera que eso es una fuente de
oportunidades pues bien la cuestión es
que luchar contra el cambio climático es
crucial siguen siendo los recursos
naturales más que nunca el factor
limitante en los límites al crecimiento
están en los recursos naturales no hay
ni para todo ni para todos entonces
los más términos optimistas suelen ser
los que se dedican a la economía y no
miran en la cara oculta de la luna pues
entonces mal vamos mal vamos tenemos que
decírselo pero la cuestión es la
siguiente que pensar que esto que
estamos diciendo no son más que
oportunidades porque tenemos que hacer
diseñar empresas que sean capaces de
desensamblar capaces de recuperar
capaces de poner en valor las cosas que
estamos haciendo los materiales no se
destruyen los materiales se pueden
utilizar una en dos y mil veces porque
no hacemos eso porque nos recuperamos
esos materiales y los ponemos otra vez y
pensar una cuestión
la economía que nos cuentan es su fijar
la economía que nos cuentan es pues
vamos a achatarrar el coche y entonces
vamos a recuperar el 80 por ciento del
vehículo no porque los metales críticos
que están allí nos nunca se recuperan y
esos son justamente los que necesita la
humanidad no penséis simplemente en el
tema de que os diría yo 20 años una
generación hombre ser humano puede vivir
mil años si destruimos esto a las
generaciones futuras a dónde vamos
entonces uno tiene que mirar que tenemos
una responsabilidad con el futuro y eso
es importante vosotros la gente joven
tenéis que ver en eso unas enormes
oportunidades en definitiva hay que
desalinea la economía hay que hacer una
economía no circular en realidad espiral
bien mirar si no lo hacemos el ser
humano empezó en la edad de piedra luego
sigo en el área de hierro luego siguió
la del carbón el petróleo la nuclear
ahora estamos en la edad de la tabla
periódica todos los metales
si continuamos así como el planeta es
finito lo que terminaremos así en la
edad de piedra
entonces
muchachos
que hay que hacer pues hay que empezar a
gestionar globalmente en los recursos no
podemos estar destruyendo el planeta
tenemos que ser conscientes de ellos hay
que escuchar a mensajes como los de get
a tumbar en el cual habla de que nos
estoy robando el futuro si nuestra
generación la mía ha sido la más
destructiva de la historia porque hemos
consumido más recursos que toda la
historia de la humanidad y además a los
que venís de atrás nos hemos dejado lo
mejor sino que hemos destruido también
el medio ambiente y además os hemos
quitado los mejores recursos esto es muy
duro lo tengo que decir tenéis que
cambiar el mundo y hay muchas
oportunidades de la industria
del gobierno de todo simplemente
tratando de ver que los metales las
cosas se pueden utilizar y reutilizar y
volverlas a utilizar el mundo nos
determina en materias primas pero sí que
lo podemos es degradar poco a poco pues
bien muchas gracias hay que dar la
vuelta y que este planeta es una rueda
única y una
[Música]